voyez le président qui trinque avec les
joueurs de Toulouse
[Applaudissements]
et c'est on est sur un cul sec du
président de la République
[Applaudissements]
je sais pas si c'était attendu à ça avec
modération évidemment
[Applaudissements]
je vois les noms là je vous dis allez je
vous donne mon avis d'abord après vous
pouvez si vous changez d'avis ou pas il
y a plein de gens qui m'ont écrit ouais
il a pété un câble président
[Musique]
vraiment je vous dis la vérité moi dans
ces cas-là je préfère cent fois ça qu'un
mec qui a un bâton dans le cul
je le fais pas non non je suis rassera
tout ça
j'ai donné mon avis moi je te dis voilà
ça me dérange pas moi c'est pas ça qui
me dérange moi franchement ça me dérange
pas moi toi qu'est-ce qui se passe moi
je trouve que cette image elle est
ridicule on dirait un ado qui ce qui
essaie de se faire accepter dans une
bande et on peut pas dire pardon on peut
pas dire aux gens que l'alcool est
dangereux pour la santé que ça détruit
des vies que c'est c'est
la vie d'alcool arrête de dire tu vois
déjà tu commences ta phrase partir une
bêtise c'est l'abus d'alcool moi je
pense que là
il est dangereux pour la santé faut pas
conduire non mais alors dans ce cas là
tu tu tu tu vois bien sûr
comme si les pensées
évidemment c'est pas de la politique il
parle pas de la réforme des retraites ou
de l'inflation là il est juste pour
faire de la de la com et effectivement
il veut utiliser la popularité de de
Toulouse et comme je suis toulousaine je
suis très contente pour avoir l'air un
peu sympa un peu genre bon poteau vous
avez vu comme je je suis drôle et tout
ça moi personnellement je trouve pas ça
scandaleux mais j'aime pas j'aime pas le
mec qui se défonce sa bouteille de
croona comme ça c'est même pas une
guerre française bon
il y a un côté un peu je trouve que de
boire une je trouve que l'image de bois
et il le dit en fait il perd à tous les
coups quoi exactement c'est très mal
connaître les 3e mi-temps comme ça parce
que quand tu es dans un groupe comme ça
ils viennent de péter bien sûr ils
viennent de fêter la victoire
allez il faut boire un coup avec nous et
bien sûr tu vois le président refuser
ridicule
non mais c'est important c'est une
ambiance une ambiance
si vous voulez réussir ne faites rien
il a voulu fêter la victoire arrête
d'être démagogo pour rien il a voulu
kiffer alors le cul sec ok c'est
peut-être un coup de conne bah oui ok
pas de problème
mais là il a voulu kiffer la victoire
laissez-le après
Sophie c'est pareil il pouvait
difficilement Raymond parce qu'elle est
réforme de retraite et cetera
effectivement le pays dans une situation
critique oui difficilement dans cette
ambiance là dire ah ben non il a raison
c'est pas ça que je suis en train de me
dire
il est en train d'énerver une bonne
partie des Français
mais c'est un contexte
le problème c'est que moi je trouve
c'est qu'il boivent la bière en entier
ils peuvent très bien faire Tchin comme
ça avec les mecs alors
j'ai l'impression d'avoir 10 ans et
d'être dans les Guignols de l'info j'ai
l'impression que c'est une caricature je
suis je suis un peu je me dis mais en
fait c'est honteux de sa part je pour
moi il est ridicule c'est pas en buvant
une bière cul sec qu'on va se faire
accepter par le peuple au contraire
il y a des choses à ne pas faire des
choses à faire je vais peut-être être
démago comme Raymond mais je m'en fous
je le dis quand même c'est pas parce que
je vais avoir une bière que le peuple va
te kiffer et on parle de Chirac Chirac
peut-être qui faisait moins de choses
mais en même temps quand tu fais plein
de choses mais tu fais que de la merde
bah ça sert à rien voilà
attention là je vous le disais je le
redis et c'est vrai que à un moment
quand tu prends des risques forcément tu
vas être tu vas être torpille sur ça
on en a parlé plein de fois des retraits
des trucs mais là les gars je vous dis
la vérité vous êtes fous quoi mais là
franchement excusez-moi moi je donne mon
avis est-ce que c'est les je ne trouve
pas
je suis désolé là-dessus tu es dans
l'ambiance c'est très compliqué de faire
tu bois tu vois tout le monde aurait dit
tout le monde aurait dit ouais il est il
passe pour un coup tu serais tout ça
à l'époque de chien qui avait pas les
réseaux donc il pouvait trouver
[Musique]
mais ça exactement ça ce genre de défi
ça s'appelle du Beach de rocking
c'est 35 ans c'est dévastateur je suis
désolé ce défi il le relève d'accord
mais c'est vraiment c'est nul faire
quelque chose qui est très dangereux
pour la santé je suis désolé
ça aurait fait naturel là je suis désolé
c'est un super mauvais message je passe
pour réagium
c'est un nom excuse-moi ce défi j'ai
l'habitude express
vous comportez comme les bobos qu'on
déteste
exactement il faut comporter comme les
bonbons qu'on déteste qui voit des
polémiques
là où il y a juste un type qui boit une
bière
effectivement c'est un président qui qui
aujourd'hui était testé par une grande
partie de la population
il y aurait eu un alors c'est ça qui va
le président
les deux présidents qui ont été les plus
détestés c'est jeudi c'est Sarkozy et
Macron qui ont été le plus décrié c'est
les deux qui ont fait le plus de choses
si tu prends Hollande il a jamais rien
fait il s'occupait d'aller chercher des
croissants d'adhésion
il a été élu 12 ans donc il a fait un
setena un quinquennat et Julie je vous
dis lui-même disait à ses ministres leur
disait ne faites rien c'est le meilleur
moyen que vous avez de de pouvoir
continuer longtemps et surtout le
deuxième mandat il s'est dit vraiment je
le fais rien du tout et c'est le premier
bord de la bière partout avec tous
l'agriculture
par exemple monsieur Chirac que je
respecte énormément c'est le premier
déjà à demander la retraite à 65 ans
aussi c'est moi ils ont pas osé le faire
mais c'est ça
parce que vous parlez de retraite